un café croissant à côté d'une montagne
de déchets des rues devenues des
dépotoirs en une semaine le visage de
Paris s'est transformé et pour les
riverains difficile de l'accepter il y a
des rats et tout l'image de Paris la
ville lumière bah dis-donc elle est
belle elle éclairée la belle lumière
c'est une honte j'ai entendu Anne souris
souris adjointe écologiste au maire de
Paris en charge de la santé publique
dire c'était sur BFM il n'y a aucun
problème sanitaire à ce que des enfants
soient au contact des rats gère
sincèrement
parisien
qui qui problématique
regardez ces images là on est en 2023
les Américains qui regardent emilyn
Paris c'est qui viennent
comment la publicité mensongère
qui viennent à Paris tombe là-dessus on
est en 2023 en France à Marseille
il y a des grèves des éboueurs à
Marseille tout le temps
question complètement
ibérique Mélanie
Richard
de Paris demande la réquisition d'au
moins un site d'incinération qu'on
puisse évacuer des des déchets mais pour
le moment elle est du côté de ceux qui
sont bloqueurs encore aujourd'hui Anne
Hidalgo a rappelé son soutien en
gréviste et laisser son premier adjoint
répondre le meilleur moyen de remettre
les éboueurs au travail c'est de retirer
la réforme je vous dis mon soutien total
entier à ce mouvement social et lorsque
cela concerne en plus des catégories de
personnels de la Fonction publique du
secteur privé je dis au gouvernement
déjà parlé avec eux déjà essayé de
comprendre ce qui sont en train de vous
dire et puis on parlera de la suite
c'est de la c'est de la politique
l'image du jour pour finir c'est Johnny
Depp qui à cause de la grève des
éboueurs ne sera ramassé que mercredi le
pauvre
[Musique]
Marie
magique
fantastique regardez moi j'adore Paris
c'est beau Paris oh merci Anne merci
Emmanuel vous avez rendu la France
encore plus belle qu'elle n'était allez
les enfants tous pour Hidalgo tous pour
Manu
youpi cela mut certain
d'autres pas du tout pour les
restaurants je les plains beaucoup parce
que moi j'habite là en face je suis pas
gêné hein mais les restaurants c'est
dégoûtant même les poubelles du
président n'ont pas été ramassées
regardez dans l'Élysée
arrondissement parisien fait partie des
arrondissements ou les poubelles ne sont
pas ramassées dans le 8e arrondissement
que se trouve le palais de l'Élysée
Emmanuel Macron et regardez pas de
passe-droit pour le chef de l'été les
poubelles ne sont pas ramassées devant
le palais de l'écouter
celle du Palais de l'Élysée après la
grève des éboueurs moi j'aime bien parce
que les poubelles qui débordent l'odeur
depuis très faction les rats sur les
trottoirs ça me rappelle mes vacances à
Marseille ça me fait penser à l'été au
soleil c'est une petite rivière
naturelle qui se jette ici mais pas
seulement
ce qu'elle charrie vous allez avoir un
indice en regardant ce qui se trouve
juste derrière les calanques
donc là si je prends le tunnel et que je
remonte j'arrive à la station
d'épuration de Marseille exactement tout
à fait sinon de voir ça en plein milieu
d'un parc national
[Musique]
est-ce que tu vas bien
je n'y comprends plus rien
prends soin de toi le monde
ne te laisse pas aller comme ça
vous apercevez derrière le banc de
poisson un courant marron
c'est ça la sortie de la station
d'épuration
en plein cœur du parc national
le tuyau aurait pu être prolongé pour se
déverser au large loin de la zone
protégée
le projet a été envisagé un temps mais
jamais financé vous connaissez l'angois
Céline oui je connais et là-bas il y a
un super atelier de silvothérapie donc
c'est un atelier en forêt et n'hésitez
pas ce sera donc ce weekend 19 mars
14h17h pour vous reconnecter
profondément à la forêt ressentir la
force des arbres santé et vous recentrer
sur votre fougère
et ça marche bon
pseudo bien choisi 32 ans influenceurs
et en plus moi je tricote partout et
tout le temps donc quand je prends quand
je prends les transports pour aller au
travail bah je tricote donc du coup je
tricote dans le RER les influenceurs
font aussi partie de votre périmètre
façon multiple dérives vous avez décidé
de lancer une concertation est-ce que
certains produits certaines marchandises
vont être interdits à la vente par ces
influenceurs il faut simplement que les
influenceurs qui sont créatifs qui
représentent des emplois de la
créativité française soit soumis aux
mêmes règles que celle auquel vous vous
êtes soumis à la radio à la télévision
dans les médias traditionnels plus 48%
d'antipsychotiques plus 62%
d'antidépresseurs plus 78% de
psychostimulants chez les moins de 20
ans et ce en l'espace de 7 ans seulement
des chiffres qui font froid dans le dos
mais qui n'étonnent pas Julien quasi toi
mon groupe d'amis comme ça pression
scolaire réseaux sociaux ou encore effet
post covid plusieurs facteurs
expliqueraient l'explosion de ce type de
traitement chez les jeunes
qui s'était battus et justement les
dérives dans ce
il a raison de rappeler qu'il y a des
dérives qu'elles soient inacceptables
nous y mettrons fin mais je le rappelle
c'est un dispositif pour protéger les
influenceurs certainement pas pour les
stigmatiser Bruno Le Maire Booba même
combat ce sera le mot de la fin merci à
vous merci à vous et bonne journée